[موسيقى]
في سن الخامسه عشر تتواجد رونالدو في
لشبونه باكاديميه سبورتاج بدا يعاني من
مشاكل جسديه في القلب وكان يحتاج لعمليه
جراحيه عاجله
في خطر
كريستيانو يعتبر رياضيا مثاليا في نظامه
الغذائي وايضا يعطي الراحه اهميه كبيره
تقارير صحفيه اشارت الى ان النجم
البرتغاليه
عمو 2005 في والده دينيس افيرو بسبب ادمان
الكحول هي واحده من الاسباب التي جعلت ابن
مديره لا يتعاطى لاي مشروب نوحي
شركه حياه جورجينا رودريغيز اسبانيا
الجنسيه من اصول ارجنتينيه تعرف عليها وهي
تشتغل في احد المحال التجاري للملابس بدات
علاقته 2015
ابنه جونيور هو ايضا لاعب كره قدم تنقل
معه في ابرز محطاته لاعبه مع الفئات
السنيه الصغرى لريال مدريد ويوفنتوس
ومانشستر يونايتد كما يحضر بعلاقه خاصه مع
ابنه ويحرص على كل التفاصيل سواء بالنظام
الغذائي كما يحرص على دراسته
صاحب الخمس كره الذهبيه لديه صاله العاب
خاصه في بيته ولا يكتفي فقط بالحصص
تدريبيه مع نادي الاحياء كما لديه جهاز
استشفاء بالتدريب
ويعتبر رونالدو من الرياضيين الذين يهتمون
بالمظهر الخارجي البرتغالي لديه علامه
تجاريه خاصه به للملابس والعطور هو اكثر
شخص متابع في انستغرام مع 524 مليون متابع
منشور ضيعائي يساوي حوالي مليون يورو
[موسيقى]
هيثم بن حماد العربيه